let's go out to salt lake city utah and
talk to sheree
what is going on oh you know what hey
listen glad
i have the chance to talk to you well i
am thrilled to talk to you
it's sherry right yes yes it's sherry
all right okay so good
i immediately listen you have to know
this
the call screener zack is is sitting in
for kelly today
and he got on my headset and said it is
not sheree it is sherry and i said great
and i probably answered the phone what's
up cherie so
i need everyone in america to know that
was my fault not not his
so go for it oh well
my question is well i'm trying to figure
out right now
how i get my 16 year old to focus on the
future
without driving her absolutely crazy in
the process
uh oh i've heard this call before so
so let's give us a little bit more uh
detail on what this conversation has
looked like to this point
then i will answer that okay well um
i'll first tell you a little bit about
my daughter she's she's 16
she'll be 17 in a couple months she's
very bright she's kind she's witty
she's sarcastic she's articulate she's
very artistic and um
she has big big dreams of doing
something
like in in in hollywood or going to new
york
and being a performer or being a voice
actor or being an artist
and and i know she's so good
at all of this she is she's very good at
all of this
but i'm trying to kind of let her know
gently that
there might be a chance of her having to
do
something while she's
getting her foot into the field and she
doesn't want to hear any of that like
what what's your what's your suggestion
what do you mean well um my my
suggestions to her
is to to look at some things to what you
can do
for your your day job while you are
searching for this while you're um and
while you're improving your
wait a second okay so all right so let's
let's recap sherry because i want you to
hear what you told us
we started off a phone call saying guys
i need your help
uh helping my 16 year old take her
career or her future seriously
i asked for more details then you went
into how bright she is and how talented
she she is and how big her dreams are
so sherry we have a conflict
we don't we don't need to help her get
serious about her future
she's dreaming big that's what i would
want to give as a gift to every parent
of every 16 year old in the world
is a kid who's dreaming big sherry
that's really good
news it's sherry your safety muscle
your parenting gland i'm making these
things up they don't exist john
there's no for sure a parenting gland
there is it's you're 11
it's on overdrive right now and you're
like you're basically telling your
kid you need a plan for when your dream
fails that's what you're telling your
daughter and i know you're not saying
that
but that's what she's hearing and the
reason she's hearing that sherry
is because that's what you're projecting
so sherry i love you
i've got three teens sherry i'm not
picking on you
but guess what this kid knows that when
she goes to new york or la
she will have to pay rent and she will
have to come up with food
this kid knows this don't you think yes
or no she does
she does all right so listen so that's
what i'd call a day job
three or four waitressing gigs or
whatever she's got to do but that's not
what you're talking about you're trying
to talk her into
some type of safe career back up like
being
you fill in the blank and that is
driving her bananas and she's going mom
i don't want to do that and can i also
just set you free sherry because you're
the one that needs to be set free
if she goes for those dreams and i hope
she does and i hope you're her number
one cheerleader because if she goes for
it and it doesn't work out for whatever
reason
she'll fall back to something but we
don't we don't encourage our kids if
they play in a sporting event or they
play
a musical instrument hey it's your
recital next week do a good job
but have a good excuse in your back
pocket if you don't play well would you
ever dream of telling your kid that
no but that's what you're telling her in
her life
so mom you need to relax and you need to
say how can i support
you and how can i help you and i'll help
you find a job i'll help you find a
place where you can rent
i'll help you find a second or third
roommate i just want to support
your dream anything that that dad and i
can do to help you stay afloat
and stay in the game while you go for it
i'm all in babe
that's what you need to be telling her
and okay
to make your heart feel a little bit
lighter here because you are going to
have to do
your work here 16 year olds are 16
right 16 year old or 16. and so
when a parent goes full in support on
their dreams like ken says
one of two things will happen you will
you will help
fill that rocket with jet fuel and it
will take off
or they will realize it's not as cool
when mom thinks it's cool
right yeah the second thing is this
sherry if i look back over the arc of my
career
i've done a lot of schooling and setting
a lot of classes
if i was to tell you the number one
thing
that i have fallen back on as a senior
administrator at multiple universities
now in this
cartoon job that i have right now i'm
just living this
fantasy world has been my experience
in theater my experience playing with
music groups
my experience in front of other people
that will help her
if she decides as ken said if this thing
doesn't work out down the road
you will never the skills you learn
working on a team and
on a film crew the skills you learn
speaking in public
having to come up with learn lines and
project them and to help learn from all
these different
bosses all of those things will go into
her repertoire
and she will take over whatever else job
she wants to do so you can't
lose by encouraging your daughter to
work as a team work on a team
as a part of her art work on her art
what you can do though is
man she wants to go all in man let her
know
like matthew matthew mcconaughey told us
yeah dad said
you're going to go all in you're going
to go all the way up you're going to
work really hard don't screw this up
that's right and here's the deal sherry
uh you gave me enough evidence to
believe that this is not a delusion
that she does have the talent so what so
if she doesn't make it on the la level
or the new york level
who cares maybe god's got a different
place for her but it was pursuing that
path
that led her to her ultimate position if
a kid's delusional parents
yeah shoot them straight let them know
the real real okay
but this this girl's not delusional
she's got a dream and she's got talent
to back it up so
uh i would tell you sherry uh maybe even
an apology might be necessary here not
that you've done anything really wrong
but just say hey babe
i care so deeply about you as your mom
i'm always trying to protect you
uh and the reality is is maybe i tried
to protect you too much
here's how i'm going to support you
that's what i think is is necessary here
and then let her fly
i love ken the idea of a parent taking
their kid out and saying
yeah you know what i've been the brakes
here yes
and so starting today yeah i'm going to
be your number one fan
but if we're going to do this we're
going to go all in yeah and you're going
to get really good at this
you're going to take classes and you're
going to work really hard and end
right and i'm going to be on the front
row of your plays and i'm going to
whatever that looks like
we're going to support you we're gonna
support you all in i love that ken
well let me tell you something i deal
with adults who call the ken coleman
show every day that are 35 and 45
and they feel like they don't know what
they do and as i begin to dig and ask
them questions i've had so many
just break into tears men and women and
i'll say
why didn't you pursue it this thing that
we just got out of you
and i can't tell you how many times
they've said because
my mom my dad told me to do something
smart and safe
and smart and safe is sucking
the soul out of people that's what's
happening
you were created to fill a unique role
you are needed you must do it and
parents we got to wake up because if we
try to
push our kids into a safe college and a
safe degree and a safe job we
might be stepping on their very souls
i can tell you that how many i'm fired
up law students
pre-med students medical student
i've talked to and then said i said what
are you doing here they can't stand say
i have to there's the only way it's my
only path i
minister students any amount of students
teachers
you don't like teaching you don't like
kids right my mom said this is this is
what we do yeah in our family yeah
parents follow your heart and not
recklessly not idiotically
and as kids said you'll know i've met
with a lot of students that are like hey
i'm supposed to be a singer and then you
hear them sing and you're like
no you're not you're not yeah but if
your kids got the talent get behind them
support them the world has plenty of
people that will tell them that they're
not good enough yep
let you be their cheerleader get in
their corner this is the ramsey show